this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
the water we swim in is dangerous and
someone has died in it
growing up i had people tell me that the
water was so dangerous that there were
three prisoners who didn't make it and
the reason alcatraz was there was
because they had sharks in the water and
you can't swim at all but now i know
that's not true
i'm natali i'm 16 and i've swum from
alcatraz to san francisco 48 times i'm
anaya i'm 12 and i'm on the alcatraz
swim 38 times and natalie is my sister
i used to be the youngest person to swim
the span of the golden gate bridge but
my sister holds that world record now
the first time i swam alcatraz was when
i was 10 years old and i was inspired by
my friends who had swum it before me
we train once a week every sunday with
our open water swim team
from just alcatraz to the beach that
takes me around 35 to 40 minutes but my
fastest time is 27 minutes
57.5 right now
that water is freezing but you feel so
good because you're in the open ocean
the water is mercury you can't really
see anything but you can feel the water
and you feel like you're on top of the
world
but you're in the middle of the ocean
it's hard to have that mental strength
that you can do this because it's just
so dangerous and unusual to do it and so
whenever we
swim when i take a breath and she takes
a breath we end up looking at each other
and it's really comforting to see that
there's someone out there with you while
you're swimming
[Music]
people are generally
very shocked that's the first response
because it's something that no one's
ever really thought of doing
i grew up with this so i never knew a
world where it was unusual to do this if
other kids want to do this i encourage
it
[Music]
you